pour non respect de la législation sur
les cookies la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés condamne
google et amazon à des amendes record
100 millions d'euros pour google 35
millions d'euros pour amazon le gendarme
de l'internet en france reproche aux
deux géants du web de déposer des
traceurs publicitaires sur l'ordinateur
des internautes sans qu'ils aient donné
leur accord au préalable par ailleurs
selon la cnil les bandeaux d'information
affiché lors de la consultation de ces
sites ne contiennent pas d'informations
suffisamment clair pour que l'internaute
sache à quoi servent ces cookies et la
façon dont il peut les refuser
deux éléments justifient la décision de
la cnil l'importance des infractions
constatées qui portent atteinte à la vie
privée des internautes dans leur
quotidien numérique et la taille de ses
entreprises
le moteur de recherche google détient
une part de marché supérieure à 90% en
france amazon possède plus de 20% du
marché français du commerce en ligne
il manipule les données personnelles de
dizaines de millions de français
les deux entreprises américaines ont
vivement critiqué la décision de la cnil
google a défendu son bilan en matière de
transparence et de protection de ses
utilisateurs grâce à des informations et
des paramètres de confidentialité clair
une infrastructure sécurisée et surtout
des services utiles amazon estime que
les coûts qui aident les clients à
profiter des fonctionnalités
essentielles à l'expérience d'achat sur
son site google et amazon en trois mois
pour modifier leurs bandeaux
d'information une astreinte de 100 mille
euros par jour de retard sera appliquée
après expiration de ce délai